Hi, my name is Benjy
Braun and I'm really
excited to talk to you
today about getting data
science in your
customers' hands quickly
and on a budget using
RStudio Connect.
This is an unconventional
use of this product,
which is really geared towards
internal apps and resources.
But I want to show
you how you can
use this product for customer
facing applications as well
as internal ones.
But before I get
into that, I wanted
to set the scene
for how we started
using RStudio Connect to publish
customer facing data science
applications.
It was back in the
summer of 2020.
We all remember,
but maybe we'd like
to forget that time
in addition to being
in the middle of a lockdown
and without childcare,
my family and I had
moved in with my in-laws
to get some extra support.
Moreover, my wife had gone full
time on her own new business
back in January
2020, while I had
joined a startup as the first
technical employee in February
2020.
Needless to say, it
was a stressful time.
I have a feeling this
is a picture many of you
with kids have or at
least can relate to.
If you don't have kids,
just imagine everything
you're doing back
in summer 2020.
But add a two-year-old
and a four-year-old
to the mix as all
this was going on.
My company, 202 Group, was
dealing with a problem.
We had built a good,
streamlined data pipeline.
We had sourced necessary data
we needed to make actionable
insights for our customers
and built the methods to
ingest and store that data.
We had effective ways
to analyze and model
the data and customize
visualizations for
end customers.
We were using open
data and data science
to expose risk in critical
national security supply
chains, and our customers
were clamoring for more
so they could take action.
But despite this tested
problem, this tested process,
we had a problem.
We had a really poor UI/UX
if you could even call it that.
We were delivering everything in
PDFs, PowerPoint and Excel CSV
files.
This is a big problem
for two reasons.
The first is that once
PowerPoints or PDFs
or spreadsheets left our inbox,
it was immediately out of date.
The customer could still get
value out of it, but they
relied on us emailing
them updates, which were
out of date almost immediately.
They needed an on
demand up to date data.
The second problem
was that it wasn't
an appealing way
for the customer
to consume the analysis.
At first you might not think
that's such a big problem,
but if your customer
doesn't like
the way they interact with your
product, they won't use it.
So if you actually
want your analysis
to be anything more
than a science project,
you need to make sure
your customer likes
the way they interact with it.
And for us as a small
bootstrap startup,
our customer liking the product
meant still being in business
by the end of the year.
The customer needed to be able
to explore on their own
in a user friendly way and
get the data into formats
that they were comfortable with.
It needed to be dynamic
to fix the stale data
problem and the static
interface problem.
But we had other
requirements as well.
We needed to get this out the door
quickly in the next few weeks,
not months.
And we didn't have very
much money to do it.
Last but certainly not
least, we needed something
where we could continue to
focus on the data science
portion of our company.
The thing that was
differentiating us,
the value we were actually
delivering to customers
was the data science finding,
not the interface itself.
Learning web
development technologies
like CSS, HTML, JavaScript.
PHP would not only
be a distraction,
it would actively detract
from our time developing
the data science, which is where
we were really driving value.
So based on all this,
we developed a set
of five criteria that we would
use to evaluate the proposed
solutions to this problem of
getting up to date data science
products in our
customer's hands.
It had to be cheap, like
a few thousand dollars tops.
It had to be easy to use.
We needed to be able to
focus on the data science
and not spend a lot of time
figuring out web technologies.
It had to be easy to customize.
Our customers were still
figuring out what they wanted
and we needed to be able
to adapt and make changes
quickly and easily.
The user had to log
into an interface
the customer needed to be
able to access up to date info
when they needed it.
Emailing static reports
had to end, and last
we had to retain our IP.
Getting locked in with a vendor
didn't seem like a good idea.
And we wanted to maintain
flexibility in the future
if we started doing
something new.
So we settled on three options.
We considered third party BI
tools, like Tableau or Power
BI, hiring a front end developer,
and last RStudio Connect.
Some of my teammates were
pushing for this option.
I was against it
for a few reasons.
The startup costs are
actually pretty expensive,
which is a big driver
for us at this point.
But there are two other,
perhaps more important reasons.
One is that learning to
use one of these tools
was really a poor
use of our time.
We already knew how to
use R Markdown and Shiny.
Why learn how to use
one of these tools
when we could be
developing data science?
If we were going
to use these tools
and learn how to use
them from scratch,
we might as well learn
JavaScript ourselves.
These tools might market
themselves as easy to use,
but in practice I
don't think it's really
that easy, especially
if you want
to produce something appealing.
Second is that we'd get
locked into the vendor
and switching costs
would be high.
Anything we'd develop would
be specific to the vendor's
product and we'd lose
flexibility if we
wanted to do something else.
So a third party BI tools
had two out of three.
I was ready to move on.
What about hiring for this need?
The problem here
was that it wasn't
going to be cheap
to get someone good.
And while it might be easier
than doing it ourselves,
it would be hard to
source someone good
and then manage them
through the process.
We also wanted to stay
focused on our value, which
was in the data science and
hiring outside of that would
also have been a distraction.
If we were going
to hire, we'd want
to hire another data
scientist or engineer.
So better than the third
party tools, but still
only three out of five.
So this left us with
RStudio Connect.
I was only familiar
with this product
because I had goofed around
enough in the RStudio IDE
and clicked on this button
here the Publish button.
This was really helpful
when I published the blog
using RPubss.
So the idea of a button
in the RStudio IDE
to publish R Markdown
and share them securely
was really appealing.
Then when we got in
touch with RStudio
with RStudio about
using Connect,
I found out about the
small business discount.
This made this option
far and away cheaper
than the other
options we considered.
And since we got to
keep using R Markdown,
we didn't have vendor lock in
and we retained all our own IP.
So checks across the board.
It checked all the boxes, which
is why we use it going in.
But the reason why we
continue to use it,
and I'm such an evangelist
for it now, is what made it
successful. We were able to change,
update and push content
quickly.
We could respond to customers,
both in terms of access
and data within minutes.
And as time went on,
we were iteratively
able to learn more web
and front end technologies
and incorporate them
into the end product.
This included custom
CSS and JavaScript
to give our products
a unique look and feel
and better user experience with
only minimal front end needs.
So we've gotten to the point
based on customer needs
and where we are as a company
that we now do deliver a product
and a custom JavaScript PHP front
end with a dedicated
front end team.
And now we use RStudio Connect
for its more conventional
purpose of hosting
internal products.
But what's awesome is that
everything we developed
was in R Markdown, so
those rendered HTML docs
and graphics could be used
by our front end developers.
So I want you to
think about our story
and how it might work for you.
If you're a small business or
even an individual and you're
not sure how to get
your data science
into your customers' hands,
think of RStudio Connect.
It's cheap, easy to
use, easy to update
your, update your products,
lets your customers
log into an interface
and lets you retain all
your IP without vendor lock in.
Please feel free to
reach out to talk
about this or anything else.
Thank you so much for your time
and coming to hear my talk.